hello there reject nation we are going
to watch brooklyn nine-nine season one
episode five today i am very much
excited to check this out brooklyn
nine-nine
is a cathartic release of laughter that
we all must use
once in a while guys subscribe to john's
solo channel
it's called the real rejects that's
right welcome on it's my guest today i
appreciate it
hit that like button to show john's
miniature channel some support
guys over at john's patreon page there's
a full length ratchet watch the logs
where you stick it with the time code
for brooklyn nine-nine and over there
he lets me guest star on a few of the uh
reactions as well and
sometimes let me do my own solo one very
graciously to let me use your platform
any time except only the times that i
allow you to that editor you're
constantly talking with your best friend
i love that guy great so sexy so
john thank you for letting me uh try out
introduction
introduction introductions good you got
there you got there and that's
not important all right i'm working on
it but you should beat yourself up about
that
i i i learned from the best
you do you did should we is this for the
time where we watch it no i think we
should stretch this intro out to like
two or
three minutes audiences like that they
do they love that let's do a sponsor
segment
you guys see the dude i brought in today
the drug dealer 81 years old
i think it's the oldest collar of my
entire career i once arrested a 96 year
old for
flashing my oldest caller was 78 but the
pcp made her fight like she was 20.
you're talking oldest bags 68. that's
not that old
yeah but i was only 20. 20. were you
even a cop then no man it was before i
got into the academy
[Laughter]
charles isn't talking about his oldest
arrest
god you had sex with a 68 year old when
you were in your 20s
you know how it is when you have a
chance to bet an older woman
that's someone's grandma she was
actually that's how i met her grandson
marvel
live your truth boy seems like a genuine
laugh
i know it almost looks like they played
a trick on him
with the scene i think as an actor it's
it's harshy to just probably create a
genuine laugh
yeah especially doing so much coffee for
some reason the d.a won't move forward
with the arrest
until we find the knife she used is that
reason that they want to win the case
yes we'll find it i'm going to ask you
again do you need any resources or
personnel no sir i've got it okay
dismissed sergeant jeffords my office
uh-oh
he probably wants to talk to you about
how your shirts aren't tight enough
probably
but i work best alone except when it
comes to sex
actually sometimes including sex me too
okay fine i will let one of you help
charles
yeah and i am choosing charles because
he's the least likely to steal my
thunder
i would never steal his thunder i i'd be
afraid to borrow it
feel your truck accompany me to a gun
range you mean drive you there and wait
outside
i need some pointers sir i haven't found
a weapon since the incident
the mannequin incident are familiar the
pilot
actually there was an incident after
that
another incident
oh no
[Laughter]
i'm gonna get some candy i'll keep it
low-key
we'll go after work to a private range
no cops
no pressure i told gina she could join
us
yeah it's your type
all right this one's all you tiger come
on
police hey man
oh my god here hold this oh no
i should do it for crazy ex-girlfriend
hey
i looked at the photos of your victim on
your desk is that rosa hillary said hi
puncture wounds are similar to a case i
had a while back they aren't from a
knife
i think it's something spiral like a
corkscrew oh you better get back here
now oh no i think
competition oh
hello peralta who's this sir 30 rock
yeah and those commercials mayhem
yo how much you bench seriously
[Laughter]
nothing i can do you're off the case i
can't believe you're just rolling over
and giving my murder away to the vulture
you're the one who insisted on working
alone i mean rose is the one who figured
out the corkscrew
and charles caught a dog
you should have involved them sooner
turn over your files to detective
pembroke
sir call him the vulture giving him a
name makes him human turn
over take odds on how fast i'll solve
this case
no i mean what was it with diaz's last
impossible extortion case
what was it six hours that's because it
was 98
solved the last two percent's hardest to
get that's why they leave it in the milk
what
[Laughter]
foxy ma go rotten hell this is your
fault
thanks champ good effort i got it from
here
and hey you feel free to call me anytime
you need me to come down here and help
powder that big white ass of yours
well that's sexual harassment yeah you
could report him
sorry you got vulture happens to the
best of us on my count
one two three i got it from here
[Laughter]
dick you say and it will
oh thanks guys i got it from here i'm
buying everyone drinks as long as we're
here thinking of a revenge plan
best idea gets 50 bucks throw him on out
what if you called him from a hospital
and said his whole family is dead like
he died of cancer
charles that is so dark i'm putting it
down
[Laughter]
all right back your left foot up a hair
oh like such a good mentor
no gina
thick muscular arms around me and um
all right look hands here stand up
straight chin
forward hold on my nose itches smart
listen all right all right look hey both
of you
just watch
he's he's back he back
why are you counting my shots are you
trying to have me re-certified
yes if you make eight of ten shots i can
sign off on you
carrying a gun again gina's here as an
official witness and i thought it'd be
easier for you in a
no pressure environment you only have
one hit
until you get re-certified so deep
breath
huh take the final shot
i thought you said effort
take the [ __ ] like you've done your
whole life
oh my god guys
how do you breathe it's a two win one
hour
all right give me your hair dryer don't
you carry one in your purse
have you ever met a human woman i just
need a second
we've had 18 minutes of seconds hey it's
peralta
oh hey jake hey do you carry a hairdryer
in your purse
of course i'm not an animal great
uh i need you to bring it to the
vultures apartment there's someone named
the vulture tell rosa
peralta why are you asking gina about
detective pembroke oh captain hello uh
we are
look i understand that you're upset but
if you want to keep this from happening
again
i suggest that you pull your team
together and solve these cases
before major crimes can step in you
should be frowning
why is jake smile why are you smiling
because the captain just gave us the
perfect revenge plan
we team up and solve this case
we're angry we're getting revenge we're
a little bit tipsy
we should not be driving we're taking
the bus
[Laughter]
let's all just count to a million one
two three four five six
so then iceman says you can be my
wingman any day
and then man i haven't what happens next
goose comes back right he's not really
dead
i know i know i know
i say we role play see if something
sparks darling thank you for a lovely
dinner perhaps we should have one more
drink before bed
wife goes into the drawer gets the
corkscrew stab stab stab
what did she do with the corkscrew she
dumps in the hallway trash chute on the
way to the doorman no we checked the
trash like 10 times we would have seen a
bloody corkscrew
the body the corkscrew still
okay i want in but i only want to stab
you fine
charles dork chemistry uh oh
and complimentary shirt colors
sweetheart
time to die that seems a little harsh
what if it was a magnetic corkscrew
if the corkscrew was on a magnet it's
stuck halfway down the inside of the
trash cut i figured it out
ah someone's gonna have to go down in
there someone with narrow shoulders
no i have broad shoulders i have narrow
hips but broad shoulders
god oh see anything a little lower
freeze hands in there
we're cops broad shoulders stuck
[Laughter]
that's the crime scene and an officer
has gotten stuck in a trash chute
i need you to lead this criteria i mean
really lead it hell yeah i'm upset
your team disrupted a crime scene
voila you actually found the corkscrew
in the trash chute
stuck to the side just like you said
this is the proudest moment
oh
before you get mad shut it hope was
right i've been so worried about my own
kids i forgot about my stupid growing up
kids
it's insulting but if you ever do this
again
i swear i will crush your head in one
hand you don't mean that
try me okay it's not your fault either
and it's not the vulture's fault it's
[Laughter]
amy's
pembroke i'd like to cordially invite
you to calm down
especially considering that this case
has already been solved
by you it's a good thing you realized it
was magnetically stuck to the inside of
the trash chute
we're done here yeah yeah we're done
here
keep up the bad work champ here comes
why does he keep touching my butt
everyone involved tonight is gonna get
written up okay fine
here's everyone who was there jake
peralta jay peralta
dr jacob peralta no one else was there
i'm happy to see you learning how to be
part of a team
everybody go home sleep it off and sir
thank you ultimately it was our raw
sexual chemistry that helped
[Laughter]
you could join my dance troupe floorgasm
we're looking for a man of precisely
europe
jake i have to say the way you handled
things with the vulture yesterday was
very mature
credits every time i know
oop time's up i can't wait to see it ah
here we go oh
suction check it out
perfect right yeah dear
vulture enjoy
my big white ass jake
there you are always take the high road
charles
always take the high road
[Laughter]
life advice oh hell yeah
ah a genius
genius show um genius john
utter delights i loved every second
of this one even gina even
shout out gina whenever we love her she
helped out this time she came
in clutch
yeah you know like this this was like
the most ensemble episode they've done
yeah you know what i mean like they're
just paired up as a team
they're all underdogs so i'm handling
little files thingy here
while i'm talking to y'all and yeah
yeah and they all have to learn like you
know the
they all have a lesson to learn together
but then they still keep it focused with
like having
um you know not terry hatch or terry
crews
terry hatcher yeah yeah who else is
terry crews
and then having uh you know jake having
to learn his lessons as well
but they're all kind of learning
together and but you also get to see
them
bond and i love like the lived in
quality of
like when they're at the bar they're
just being new yorkers and then they
even take the bus
to the private seat it's like they
really
it's called brooklyn 99 and you really
get a vibe for
brooklyn and not just the the stage
where they film
yeah yeah it's not like it's only in the
precinct in like the same apartment set
yeah yeah that's great
no yeah totally i mean this was and i've
been hoping you know that we would see
that kind of unfold over these episodes
is you know
obviously andy sandberg is like the
centerpiece but they do have like such
an appealing ensemble
and to you know watch as these dynamics
start to unfold especially like you know
i'm excited to see more of uh
like amy's character come out with the
comedy like
like that was um i feel like she had
maybe
some of the funniest singular moments
but also like the least in terms of the
ensemble vibe so i'm excited to see like
her comedy come out more but um
yeah i don't know this this i don't yeah
it's like it's taking it
to another level of that i'm not really
articulating in any way eloquently but
yeah that makes me so happy because
usually you are
and i'm like oh man he's articulating so
well
and i'm not yeah and then i just gets
more self-conscious and caught up in my
head about how well you're
because you say like some big word in
the middle of
just talking casually like soliloquy
so yeah in fact i'll go off on another
soliloquy now that i have better things
to say
but i like how this yeah satisfied that
hope of mine
as a viewer that yes like you know all
of the characters will start to become
highlights no matter what
and and that the ensemble grows out but
also that we get some progression
for terry's character and whatnot and
you could get the sense that even though
there are these types and everything and
everyone has a specific personality you
can see their dynamics and roles being
something that's a bit more alive than
your
average sitcom necessarily yeah
that's very true um
this just makes me happy i know i just
want to hang out with them all day
this is going to sound silly to you guys
of why like a a good comedy can go
because not only do you guys check up
with us from for the few minutes
of our 24-hour days uh when we have a
camera pointed at us when we're talking
but there's also live stuff that's
happening
simultaneously you know if we don't come
on and
vlog or talk about 99 of the life things
that are happening
right yeah that's mainly what it is
physical
ailments that's my vlog i had
too many bowel movements guys gonna take
some eye drops my eyes are a little dry
right now
yeah it's really nothing fascinating my
new [ __ ]
so um you know to have a show like this
that that is so uh
easily able to thrust you into feeling
like the best kind of sitcoms are the
ones where you really feel like you're
hanging out
but this show has such a special quality
where uh
we've we've i we've echoed this before
and i feel like we're bound to say it
again
is that they keep the detective elements
so alive and that's what was so great
about this particular one there you feel
the camaraderie of the whole
unit together they have discussions
about even though they're friends and
then you know the the higher ups like
terry crews um the captain
holt they're like the leaders
essentially
and they kind of view the rest of them
as children in a way that they have to
parent
and uh it still feels like you know
just buddies you're hanging out with but
also still cops
and like them solving the case that's
exciting you're trying to figure it out
too
with them and they manage to keep it
funny
like while keeping it a detect it's not
exactly
edgar wright's simon pegg nick frost
esque where it's like they have two very
distinguished genres usually spliced
together in a movie
i i think it's really impressive that
they managed to keep this a
a comedy show that's still a a cop
procedural show
yeah that you can actually get engrossed
in that side of and it seems like they
consider
just as much as the wacky jokes like
even when they're in the crime scene
it's like okay let's
act this out and actually look at the
environment and even though it doesn't
go all sherlock about it you know you
can see them drawing conclusion or at
least you know you see
amy draw a conclusion and you know
there's actual
you know heft to the mystery that makes
the comedy that much better
exactly because it's like you have rosa
who's figuring out it's just knife stab
wounds um
okay it might not be a knife it might be
a corkscrew or if it's a magnet so
there's actually something kind of
exciting about that
yeah yeah and you're excited to see
everybody step
up to the plate on this one yeah do you
want them to win and
when uh and then the vulture character
whoever that actor is he's like
that's like the only role he plays right
for the commercial guy
yeah because he's a commercial guy well
even
even mayhem is uh yeah i'm mayhem i'm
i'm here to wreck your day and and
screw up your car may i'm here to wreck
your day
total like [ __ ] bro kind of
personality about the whole thing
i'm a brick in the truck of your truck
bed and i'm about to fall into the road
and cause a four-car plug but he's also
like i'm the same
sleazy lawyer in uh in john wick
yeah yeah he's got his i think his name
is dean winters and he's got his dean
winters character like the most
different i've seen him is in
wayne as the dad but even he is just
kind of like a more
dude version of this guy or a more
aggressive version of him he's also
liz lemon's [ __ ] boyfriend that's
right that's right idiot
yeah what's that it calls her i think so
hey dummy dummy yeah
uh yeah like his character too i think
is a wonderful foil to the to the group
you know
and like he plays so well off of andy
samberg yeah it's a perfect character to
set up for like okay i'm sure we'll see
this guy again at some point to wreck
their
operation but i love how there's this
real arc with him
with terry crews terry having it's so
funny
this whole time i was saying terry crews
because i'm like man i can't remember
that character's name
that's the honest thought
one character was like is absolutely
supposed to only be this guy
so much that they named him terry
real bonus points if you remember his
fictional last night i kept saying chris
just because i was
every time like what is that guy's real
name in the show
oh terry something or other
but that i love like it really does have
like a family thing
yeah like like i feel like it's not a
hard conclusion to draw but you know
you have holt and terry are kind of both
like dad
they're both they're the two dads and
then gina is that one's like
grandpa dad and the rest of you yeah
yeah yeah yeah
grandpa dad kooky aunt and then the kids
grandpa
dad not black children
you know they have a big adoptive new
york family
uh but how they brought that back
because i kind of forg
i thought it was such a funny moment in
the pilot and uh
they don't really talk about it
afterwards you see that it's a part of
his character progression
and what exactly is just like his whole
dad's side just really has
overtaken him so he's like scared to
fire a weapon
yeah it's like once he became a dad he
became so timid and he just wants to
work at a desk now so that nothing
happens to him ever contextually that is
so funny
yeah well yeah he's even talking about
it is hilarious and it's a great bit but
i think it's also nice of them to
consider yeah evolving that because you
know while it's funny to see terry crews
at a desk and to see him like freak out
and obliterate pinatas and stuff
you know it does seem like it would be
who the just comedic dynamics to have
the
ability to have him out in the field
with everybody else and to create that
extra you know
ounce of comedy well it can be the joke
can fall so it can start to fall flat if
you don't also show that he can be
good and cool at his job yeah because
like whenever he fires you're like damn
look at him like john wick
yeah he's going to look like the
headshot like the perfect shot yeah
definitely like yeah and that's the
other thing too is like you believe it
when he actually kicks it in
yeah yeah can actually take care of
business you're like oh damn that's
really badass yeah
all right guys that was a that was a
really fun episode much needed much
needed out of the week
absolute delight afternoon delight
guys subscribe click the notification
bell hit that like button you can check
us on patreon for more
and hey last but not least let's do it
christelle donovan christelle we haven't
gotten to know you yet
but we know a little bit about you you
know why christelle
because c stands for
chastity because you
take the next letter h
stands for holy because
he's christian you know because
christelle has a very
holy and a very pure sounding name
christ's name
ours stands for um
reg ridge because you love the ridge
wallets
they are great wallets you can get
yourself one today i
stands for i love you i wish i could be
you because you seem like a lovely
person yeah because you have a
freaking hot ass pledge thank you stands
for
uh systematic because you are
are very good at strategizing should i
go with strategizing
t stands for tolerant
because if you've made it this far into
the shout out and haven't turned it off
you are a tolerant person
e stands for
uh everlong
use everlong in a sentence take the next
letter song
l stands for uh
uh loquacious because i assume that you
can can bend a phrase
l stands for
like a monomi
which means you are a uh
spiritual equivalent of all the greatest
angels
in the world and and e stands for
excellent because you are
excellent and we appreciate you very
much
you just you gave us such a high pledge
and uh this should have been the best
one
of the shout outs it was and uh
we succeeded thank you for being here
this is the greatest shout out in the
world tribute and i'm sorry too on top
of it yeah